[Music]
so is this runway casting for a grumpy
brand or a smiley brand
so it's a grumpy brand yeah
congratulations show me that balenciaga
look
suddenly i'm dressed in something way
less expensive
it's h m yay valenciaga
nhlm
valenciaga
nhm
he looks paid for the tickets not better
that's what you do i sell [ __ ]
the success of a luxury cruise mainly
depends on you
i don't want to hear anybody saying no
[Music]
it's always yes sir yes ma'am
i command you enjoy the moment
no no
no
what
you say no to me no no oh so it's yes
yeah no yes
yes
the sails do you think it's possible to
wash them
i don't think that's possible ma'am
because this is a motorized vessel yeah
so we don't have any sales
if we'll say
yes
well then in that case
we will clean the sails yes of course
yes
[Music]
[Music]
a russian capitalist
and an american communism on a 250
million dollar luxury yeah
the ship is going under
[Music]
this is really bad
this is really really bad
[Music]
you